Twitter is weird hey you finished the
famous Blood Meridian congrats how how
was it
you okay that's God here
here what or is he like some migrant
star blinking through the tendrils of
the night's infinite dark do you really
think a book about the horrible violence
in the American southwest in the 1800s
is really a great thing to base your
personality around
what what is war it's not some acolyte
of the firmament unto which the ostuary
of devil suture together some tendril
from the knights infinite
Man and War nice cowboy boots forever
coupled by the interminable waning at
the commissary of false prophets still
exit some changeling born from the
prayer he's been standing by the window
for three hours now yeah I don't think
we should let him read anymore